NASA believes they may have found
primitive alien life on Saturn's moon of
Titan that's right they sent their
spacecraft Cassini up over there and
they analyzed the chemistry of the moon
surface and let's take a look at what
they found Titan is the only moon around
Saturn with a dense atmosphere that
could sustain life at least is the way
we know it - papers that publish these
findings by NASA claimed that hydrogen
gas from the atmosphere disappears at
the moon's surface suggesting that
something is breathing it in that sounds
right it sounds like something so my
first question every time we do anything
on aliens I always ask this first when
the aliens come
hmm will they kill us or we kill them
first why are they the aliens why aren't
we well if they're coming from a ship
then they're the aliens a case right but
we're the aliens to them great Oh alien
is gonna kill each other in that case
maybe but we want to each other do you
think there's any chance came up with
their alien technology and get rid of
the code yeah maybe you think that's
possible well I guess whoever would be
the alien would be the one that's going
right so if we go there yeah and we try
to join them on what was on Jupiter
really I mean I don't mean to sound like
a sci-fi not yeah no no I I think I've
always thought it was a little
problematic that will keep beaming this
signal saying hey we're here if you want
to find us we're here like why are we
telling the rest of the galaxy that
we're on a planet that has that can
sustain life for me I don't want to
sound like a nut am i sound like a nut
but lights a little world if there's an
alien that's gonna come down they're not
gonna come down to just have it like a
scientific experiment clearly they're
floating around the universe looking for
another planet to inhabit so why
wouldn't they just sort of clear us out
so that's just using the logic of what
we're doing here we know that at some
point we're gonna destroy the earth and
that's why they're trying to send you
know we're trying to do stuff on Mars
when we discovered America it wasn't
just to say like oh hey guys
it's going on you're good to see you we
wiped them out but you're basically
these are these are human instincts that
you're basing this upon I'm sure I just
think anybody who's going unless it's
the cloud alien from the gas alien from
tight I don't think he's a threat to us
the cloud one yeah yeah so you think
basically if someone discovers or some
some life-form discovers earth that
therefore the first thing we'll do is to
take it over I think it's a I think it's
a chance yeah probably one that we don't
want to risk yeah yeah yeah I mean
you've smoked a lot of pine that's
pretty much how I've come up with my
theories on oil + i5 dude don't tell him
we're on this planet the avatar theory
that that's what happened in the movie
Avatar you know we went there because we
wanted their natural resources because
we had already plummeted our I based my
non-scientific resource not just
watching Apatow I thought it was just a
write a book while a comic book once
it's really cool it's not just from
seeing it although that helped ya know
but really this is slightly joking aside
is there any chance if alien life did
come here is there any chance we
ultimately wouldn't want to kill it or
it not kill us the way we do everything
because you said human instinct or
humanism we're so afraid of what we
don't know we're afraid of what we don't
know that lives on the other side of the
cracks in the same town we've you know
what look if it's gonna have if it
happens I just you know I can't I don't
want to like think about killing
something else or fighting something
else I mean if that if that other thing
wants to kill me that badly [ __ ] it let
it kill my crew you know I I just can't
yeah I just don't want to live like that
I think that the problem now but yeah
I'm pretty sure when the aliens like
that array like right in your face yeah
I just think that the probability that
that that who's behind the controls of
the spaceship is like an alien with a
soul that's gonna have a debate with the
other aliens on the board like should we
or should we or should we not wipe out
this is probably a fallacy that that any
you know would probably a computer
that's running this machine anyway who
doesn't
got the same emotions that we would have
well I have a occasionally did oh that's
right you're right hey we're all right
let's just hope Spock is on boat when I
made my sci-fi reference that was kooky
but you're going to know about this
laughs he was the guy really no no I
mean I did but I did I was not one of
those in you know in school when I was a
maintance and when I was in school and
and what's the name of the show Star
Trek oh yeah okay you know the older
boys would come in did you see Star Trek
it you know it's all the boys I've
always talked about the Star Trek
episode the night before and I never
watched it well you got Spock right and
then you forgot the name of the show
[Music]